[MUSIC]
There are three critical communication
tools that every business leader needs to
be thinking about as he or
she communicates.
The first is to have structure
to what it is you say.
Structure is absolutely critical.
A wonderful structure to think about is
the what, so what, now what structure.
This structure helps you convey a point,
teach people things in some cases,
convince them.
You first start with the what, that is the
main point you're trying to get across.
Perhaps it's a new product
you're bringing to market.
Perhaps it's a new process
you're trying to implement.
The so what explains why it's important,
not to you, the communicator, but
to the audience.
What's the value for them?
And then the now what is what
you want your audience to do.
Having that structure helps
you formalize your thoughts,
package up your information, and it helps
you as a communicator to be concise.
[MUSIC]
The next tool you need to have is to
have variety in your communication, and
I mean variety in many different ways.
First, you need to have
variation in your voice.
What we know is monotone speakers
are boring and disengaging.
So we need to have some variation
both in our rate and in our volume.
Second, we need to have variation
in the evidence that we provide.
Whenever you make a claim,
make an argument, you need to support it,
many people, especially in
the business world, use data.
Data are critical and very important,
and I encourage people to use data,
especially if it's contextualized,
if you give it context.
But there are other ways of
supporting your claims, use stories.
Use testimonials,
that's a third party voice, define terms.
Those are ways that you can also vary,
supporting your claims.
[MUSIC]
The final tool I think every effective
business communicator needs to
have is the ability to paraphrase.
Paraphrasing is a tool that helps in so
many contexts.
For example, if somebody is making
an argument or raising a question,
yet they're very unclear and it's not for
sure what it is they need, paraphrase.
Say something like what I
think you're asking is, or
the point I hear you making is this.
That helps solidify for
them what it is they're saying and
it gives you a launching point for
your response.
Similarly, if you're in a meeting and
somebody is raising objections or
behaving rudely, you can use a paraphrase
to say, I hear what you're saying.
That's something you're
very passionate about.
What I'd like to do next is, so
the paraphrase is a polite way to move
from somebody else's communication to
where you need the communication to go.
With these three tools,
being structured, having variation,
both in your voice and in your evidence,
and using paraphrasing.
You can be very effective in the many
different types of situations you find
yourself in.
[MUSIC]